how many how many shows did you end up
working on like simultaneously is it
only like one at a time or do you do you
like have multiple shows that you're
being worked on depends on time to time
but usually two shows at a time for
animation for playing um as a producer
I'm working like five six different
shows right now oh wow how do you how do
you like just organize that all like I
mean I have some assistant producers
right or some projects I'm more um
emotionally involved in right right
invested in is there so I don't give a
[__] about this show too much give it to
the assistant
no every show to Orange matters of
course of course we can't miss I mean we
we spend it
[Music]
that's why they're the goat I agree
actually I agree I agree yeah it takes
three years for us to develop a show so
have you ever said no to be like I don't
think we would we could do this or I
don't know I mean there's a lot of times
we say that okay okay is it due to like
personal reasoning or like more like a
technical like limit or I mean right so
I mean if they were giving this certain
manga and there's like 100 as I said
they're 100 characters right right we
simply can't do this is is there any
like dream shows that you want to work
on or that you would love is there a
show where it's like orange if orange
did this show yeah it would be a banger
I'm working on this so I can't say it
you can tell us
no I'm excited because yeah so when is
the show ending I just want to know
right now uh a question that uh is is
often asked nowadays is um you know
because you do a lot of 3D animation and
right now there's a massive conversation
around like Ai and all that stuff do you
feel that there's any possibility in the
future where it somehow helps make anime
or helps the production aspect in any
form or could it be seen as perhaps a
detriment to the current model that 3D
Studios might have
I mean there's this is the there's many
issues of revolving AI there's the
morale issue there's a legal issue and I
can't even specify which issue they have
right now yeah
I mean unless we're able to feel
comfortable with that
um We're Not Gonna utilize as a tool I
mean everything eventually is a tool for
us yeah yeah but without that issue it
solved we can't really use it yeah
because like what is the general Vibe
around AI in like the Japanese animation
industry right now because we have a
vibe from Twitter
I mean that's what this Vibe is always
about yeah that's the only thing I
actually know because oh really I don't
interact with the rest of the industry
anymore oh okay because to us it's about
how can we make ourselves better yeah
yeah I mean using other parts of the
industry is not really don't have enough
time to care about the resume industry
it's like we just here to make bangers
dammit yeah I mean it sounds selfish but
I mean it's our problems that we're
facing right now of course yeah did I
solve our problems not other people's
problems has this conversation cropped
up in studio orange at all like the
conversation of AI we always have the
conversation but right now is not yet
okay yeah I mean yeah maybe in the
future if things settle but not yet
right I guess because there's always
like you know softwares that have like
Smart Tools right like there's some
things that'll you know you can tell it
hey I mean like in a weird way I guess
like fill on paint right yeah feel the
whole thing yeah in between all it's
like I guess there's always that line
that's kind of difficult with some tools
that make doing certain kind of things
an animation or whatever easier that
would technically be clashes AI but on
it's just morally using the whole
everyone's [__] input and then just
blur something out it's kind of like
getting that balance of tools that are
useful and made ethically uh between the
whole let's make an anime for me yeah
it's like to what point are you is it
morally right to automate the process
yeah right whereas like if it's too
automated then is it even it's not a
person making any sort of like how how
is that automation being done right what
is it learning from what is this maybe
even stealing from right yeah um I guess
that's the moral quandary of it all I
mean right now I mean we debug two our
own tools oh so I mean not AI tools and
just tools yeah absolutely
experience of 10 then we make the tools
and that will create us a equivalent of
experience of three so we haven't been
off to our new grads then use that then
they instantly start off from three ah
so that's the hard way of thinking what
did you mind elaborating on what tools
that you have so I mean uh one would be
the automorph face so one thing is that
CG and hand drawn the most most diff
major difference is that CG is
three-dimensional hand-drawn is not yes
um it might look three-dimensional but
the Comfort level doesn't have to be
three-dimensional to create comfort so a
lot of manga is actually not
three-dimensional it looks realistic
yeah but it's not three-dimensional yeah
because like I guess there's
always like the uh challenge of
you know having a 3D model
um is great but making sure that it
looks good on camera I guess which is
two-dimensional which is a you know a
two-dimensional thing and you had to
create a like a specific tool just for
that so we have a tool called automorph
where we want the camera to a character
and that model was automatically warp
wow so it could just this side just
completely warp this way to make sure
that on the camera it looks really
natural so like sideways manga
characters will have two eyes where it's
impossible because they're 90 degrees
Yeah but in our own Automotive it
automatically warped it so that oh [__]
okay okay so you're kind of playing
around with so you're morphing the face
to play around with perspective to make
it look more naturally like I guess
two-dimensional right yeah you guys
developed that in-house in-house oh wow
that's cool because as an experience we
know how to do it by hand but yeah we're
physically changing the model every
single shot that's just like kind of
like almost like presets a little bit
it's like okay if camera here warped the
face yeah because have you seen the
behind the scenes of like some of the
JoJo openings uh I haven't actually no
oh because like there are some shots
yeah those those are 3D and there are
some shots with some like the poses and
you there's like been some screenshots
of like what it looks like out of like
the camera perspective and like I
remember seeing one where I I think it's
like Joseph's hand was like just like
warps like ridiculously when it was
doing like one of the posts it looks it
looks so ridiculous uh when you just
change the perspective just a little bit
but on camera looks really cool yeah I
guess uh that's one thing I wanted to
ask is like when you guys wanted to yeah
obviously you know the main goal with
orange is to be like all right how do we
make the 3D animation look as pristine
and as comfortable for people who are
more used to just watching 2D animation
as possible uh when it came to that like
obviously there's been like past and
different Studios who have done 3D
animation with varying success have you
ever like gone to like look at some of
the maybe the older shows that have used
maybe a little more like primitive 3D to
kind of like get a hint of like okay
maybe if we work on this then it won't
end up like this show or like do you use
it as a reference to be like okay this
is what not to do so let's not do what
they did in this show and instead try
and fix that in our show it's more
scarce like it's actually trial and
error on their own thing right so we try
it start making it and it doesn't work
then we keep go back to the scratchboard
do it again so you never look back at
like old shows to be like that really
sucks not really okay that's good to
know
there's actually a lot of things to
focus on I mean if they're doing people
other people are doing better then it's
more time it's more better to use them
on analyzing that right right I find it
really interesting to use the word
Comfort when watching animation that's
seems it kind of makes sense why you
would say the word Comfort but
it seems very unusual to describe
animation as being comfortable right but
I suppose when we talk about 3D where
often the major complaint is that it's
it looks weird The Uncanny this year
yeah so what is it that like why do some
shows just not get that right like what
is the main thing that is the common
mistake that happens when we're talking
about 3D enemies because it's 3D yeah
yeah it's 3D why is that better I don't
know I mean they're trying to make look
something that's really not 3D so that
causes a come through right so it's kind
of like a uh I'm kind of kind of like an
uncanny valley effect so it's a little
bit different from The Uncanny value
that Pixar and stuff ran into first
right but since we're trying to shade
then we run into a different candy
is basically the cell look the
hand-drawn type of look right that you
do in 3D okay so do you specifically try
to I guess emulate the anime style do
you want your shows be seen like a 2d
show or kind of like something a bit
different from like your typical 2D
anime we start out I mean when we
started doing animation it's just
whatever we able to do at the time yeah
yeah we started as a work for hire for
other hand-drawn Studios right so we're
required to look something create
something that blends into their yeah
art style so that's where we started out
yeah because you guys worked uh like
co-worked on Black Bullet right yeah so
like what was the main role of Studio
Orange in that show ah I can't really
like backgrounds and stuff or there
should be some enemies I think that
appear in Black Bullet right or CGS oh
okay that was before my time so sorry
right no no okay yeah do you do less of
that work that kind of work now in terms
of like working on other shows uh in
terms of like 3D CD elements and now
dude most mostly focus on your own stuff
yeah I mean focusing on what our own
stuff was our Dream okay so we remained
in that but I mean sometimes we have
some open time so at that times we work
for hire for other Studios still so okay
what's her second or Community your
first like fully Studio orange producer
okay how did that come about where was
that so um it was actually how the
project started was before any producer
existed at Orange oh okay um it was the
the producer for B stars and Trigun who
wanted to do an industrious at Orange
right right and then my partner Waki was
called in from
like uh
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yes so he's
the first producer to exist in Orange oh
okay okay and I kind of like it must
have been I guess daunting to be like
yeah we're just going to do a 3D produce
anime now we've never especially when
like came out and I think it was at like
the peak of the 3D anime equals bad
stigma right and then all of a sudden
you have a fully 3D anime Atlanta
lustrous which you know at the time had
a very dedicated like manga fan base as
well right yeah I'm sure like did you
guys like get any initial backlash win
it first came out or were people like
pleasantly surprised about how did you
think no one really expected anything
until it came out right how did it came
out suddenly so yeah how did you
convince the producers to be like yeah
okay trust us trust us we haven't got
anything to uh anything to prove
ourselves but trust our resume is
practically empty but we can do it
listen we did some character animation
before uh land luscious but not as a
non-worker right did you have to like
because I I guess like my the first
thing comes to mind is remember like I
saw a documentary of when Jurassic Park
was being made there was a conversation
about whether we should do these
dinosaurs in uh you know uh stop motion
or in 3D and the VX company had to make
like just a Showcase of what they could
do did Studio orange need to do
something similar as well going into it
no I mean from the start was that it was
already decided that they wanted to do
in 3D right they wanted to do it like
luscious at Orange so the producer's job
is like figure out
[Laughter]
we have this daunting task for you
figure your [__] out wait what the [__]
I compared to I mean I guess 2D anime
has something kind of similar where I
imagine that with technology improving
it it makes it easier was it like a was
it like big leaps at all in the past
like since land of the lustrous that
have kind of made it easier or uh made
production smoother well we've done in
the past is a lot easier because we
haven't put it into tools right but
because of that time that we have we're
challenging new stuff it's never easy
for anything right yeah I've I've
noticed like I it feels like to me at
least they're from every show you guys
have produced you've always stepped up
in some different ways so even if you
made a bangership already you're like
how do we do with this better how do we
do this better yeah because like like I
I didn't think you guys could top B
stars and you did thank you it was it
was nuts like yeah episode I don't even
want to know how long episode 12. oh my
God Trigun took to produce
that last fight scene episode 12 is nuts
yeah yeah I'll go watch it actually
insane